je tombe tout de suite eu tort
c'est un cas ni ce combat pour nous
montrer à quel point ils sont supérieurs
si tu tombes pas tout de suite temmar
victoire
ici ces deux maisons prestige qui baisse
la tête et sert les clients
jeudi à commenter et pourra même chose
avec vous l'aimez loin pour un bon club
j'ai peut-être un melon que je suis
aussi un humain
non du mauvais
et on savait les lois
c'est peut-être aussi
parce que t'as pas oublier d'où tu viens
urs et y aller pas pour nous pas pour
nous
toby était boxeur ou quoi
24 donc ces paroles faut qu'ils perdent
4 kilos en quelques jours
temps
en attendant je dois pas
victor parti s'est montré qu est ce qu
il a sa trousse de mes fringues je
pensais pas tirer jusqu'à 1 juil peter
perrett 36 combats radiateur carreau
miracle c'est de vivre